as we approach the new year a lot of
folks start to think about making their
health a priority in 2023 physiotherapy
may be one way for you to address that
to tell us more about Physiotherapy and
other services offered at Cano Health
are Reuben kiwin and Judy Fleischmann
thank you for being here today thank you
for having us thank you for having us
physiotherapy is great for folks who are
dealing with arthritis and other
conditions that cause a lot of stiffness
tell us how it works well they once they
become a member of Kano they're able to
get this service we've had beautiful
testimonies of some of our patients that
came in in a wheelchair and now are
actually a McCain and they get these
shots they get some some therapies that
at some point they start walking again
they you can see it in their faces that
they're so happy the beauty also of Kano
health is that we provide transportation
so we pick them up we bring them in and
once they're there they get their
therapy but they also can participate in
other activities like our wellness
program where they can spend a little
time do a little bit of sitting yoga a
little bit of Zumba classes and the
camaraderie that they receive there is
just wonderful because they get to talk
with each other and and they just leave
really happy and that's so important and
kind of if anyone who's out there
looking you know watching this whoever's
looking for a clinic where you want to
feel at home with family yeah kind of
health is the place to go how many times
has anyone gone to a clinic and they go
in and you're just a number yeah and you
wait hours to see a doctor you go to
Econo Health you will sit there for
15-20 minutes the doctor will see you
they will sit down with you and answer
all the questions you have so they'll
give you quality time and then if you
want to stay there and visit our
Wellness Center to do yoga to do dancing
to do stretching to do arts and crafts
you can do all of that you know I'm
proud to work for a company that
believes that you know Healthcare is a
right and not a privilege you know we
live in a state right now where we're
49th in the nation when it comes to
Health Care condo health is that model
that is helping to fix our Healthcare
problems you folks have 14 locations
which means there's one close to just
about everyone and transportation too
it's a very holistic approach that you
guys are talking about very natural
indeed uh this uh it's we believe that
that is the the best way and we've seen
the results
um
again we we have had these wonderful
testimonies and um and we've got we have
some of them on tape where they say this
was me before and this is me now and um
and they just love it and we we want to
continue that and just improving our
services every day uh making sure that
they receive everything that they
deserve because they worked so hard and
now at 65 and above they deserve this
and so so much well I want to give
people the information to get in touch
with you Reuben and Judy thank you both
so much for being here uh Cano Health
has sponsored this segment and you can
get more information on the services
we've talked about by calling that phone
number
855-975-5119 or go to canohealth.com and
we'll have that information on our
website too Las Vegas now we'll be right
back
foreign